[Music]
my name is Venkat Gotama Nene I'm a
product manager with the GCE and welcome
to the session it's an introductory
session on running Windows Server
containers in google kubernetes engine
and presenting with me are you Joe and
Alex I'll let them introduce themselves
quickly
hi I'm I'm a software engineer at Google
I have been working on kubernetes and
gke for the past four years most of my
work is about no then container runtime
I'm happy to be here today to introduce
you to Windows Server continuous on Jiki
hi my name is Alex Jankowski I'm a
software architect with the data science
and analytics team at Baker Hughes a GE
company I'm a GCP customer thank you so
much Alex before I sort of like we go
into the session I just want to do a bit
of an audience poll just show of hands
how many of you are using containers
already awesome and how many of you are
new to containers still kicking the
tires a little bit great how many if you
are using Windows server containers ok
ok ok that's totally fine
and how many of you are excited to be
here to learn more about Windows Server
containers in gke yeah ok we're all in
the right session then awesome so what
I'll do by way of by way of agenda what
we'll do is we'll go and so this is an
introductory session like I said before
we'll go into a little bit of a quick
overview of Windows Server containers
and then we'll talk about you know at
length about kubernetes and gke and
running Windows Server containers in gke
but before we get into the technical
details what I wanted to do was hear
from Baker Hughes who is a who is one of
our largest customers for gke and
they've been on a multi-year journey to
transform themselves in in using
containers so let's hear from Alex as to
what they're doing at Baker Hughes and
how Windows Server containers fits into
their
in strategy Alex thank you Venkat and I
really appreciate the fact that you're
letting me speak first
as GCP traditionally does they put their
customers first so just to give a little
bit of business context bhg is the
world's first full stream company that
means a full stream of full service oil
and gas business we have about sixty six
thousand employees and operations in
more than 120 countries being full
stream means that we deal with
challenges across the full spectrum of
services in the oil and gas industry
from exploration to production
transportation and operations we see and
operate a lot of mission-critical
equipment and complex systems that
produce an ocean of data we like to say
that we operate and our challenges in
the intersection of data science
software and domain knowledge to help us
build accurate models from that data and
extract insights that make and help us
make very high impact and critical
business decisions for example a typical
oil rig produces terabytes of data per
day it can have upwards of 20,000
sensors that give information to us
every couple of seconds and our models
cannot have an impact that would cause
us to falsely shut down that oil rig for
a day because that would equate to about
ten million dollars in lost profit
traditionally the oil and gas industry
has been a data rich industry but that
data is spread around the business in
silos there is a huge variety of code
and technologies that have been used in
the industry over the past thirty years
and we have analytics that have been
proven in the field but that over time
has accumulated the technology stack
that starts from Fortran 77 all the way
to today's world where we have no js' go
net so somehow all of these analytics
need to work together they have to be
orchestrated together give past data
from one to another be orchestrated in
loops that's a huge challenge the thing
that makes it possible and easier for do
that are containers if you'd like to
learn more about how we run these
analytics and containers how we
orchestrate them at scale I invite you
to join me at this breakout session
tomorrow where we're going to dive
deeper into that and here are some
examples where we see specifically use
of
windows dependent executables so we have
legacy dll's and old compiled
executables one example is this steam
thermal model that's a Windows
executable from 95 and our own
spreadsheets great
I mean people today still do analytics
in Excel another good example is this
refinery simulation software that we
were trying to modernize and we were
able to actually transform part of it
into Linux container wrap a web UI
around it but there's this one part that
is impossible to change and that is the
licensing server that only runs on
Windows and has to run on that platform
we were able to put it in a Windows
container so I wanted to come on stage
here today so I can say this ladies and
gentlemen I have a dream
I dream of a day in the future where we
can say all containers are created equal
an @ bh GE we created this project
called depend on docker which makes it
easy for our data scientists to
containerize both on Windows and Linux
anything that they're working on we've
open sourced this please check out the
github but that is not enough the
Windows and Linux containers that we
build need to work together side by side
and we need this one
orchestration system that is going to do
that for us so let me leave you with the
words of John Lennon you may say I'm a
dreamer but I'm not the only one and
with this let me pass the mic back to
Venkat and yuju from the windows gke
team so they can tell you how they're
making all of this happen thank you so
much Alex let's now talk about making
Alex's dream a reality shall we
awesome so but jokes aside you know
outside of course making sure that we
are listening to customers and bringing
Windows Server containers to gke this is
also part of our long-standing
commitment to make sure that you know
Microsoft workloads are get a
first-class experience on GCP and this
is a statement that you see made by our
SVP words but we are really committed to
making sure that Microsoft workloads are
a first-class citizen on GCP and of
course gke as well now for those of you
who said hey you're still early in you
know considering Windows Server
containers it's a very quick overview of
Windows Server containers for those of
you who are we've been doing this for a
while this should be all obviously very
familiar it's often you know
to think of containers in the context of
virtual machines if you're new to it on
the left-hand side is what I presume
everyone in the room is familiar with
right to virtual machines typically
virtual machines you know were invented
to virtualize the underlying hardware or
the infrastructure so much so that each
of the OS and the application running on
top of the OS pretty much thinks that
it's it has the hardware to itself and
that was the you know the technology of
hypervisor now containers is somewhat
similar so it's good to think of
containers in that context where the
application and the dependent binaries
that the application depends on
essentially is the container the red box
that you see on the right hand side and
those of course many of those containers
can run inside off of a virtual machine
in GCP essentially containers are
virtualizing the underlying operating
system so much so that the application
thinks that it has os/2 itself what is
in reality we all know it's not so
that's kind of like you know a quick
overview of what containers are and in
the world of Windows server containers
they're very similar to Linux containers
of course there are a couple of
differences that will kind of highlight
in the next few slides but you want to
think of a Windows Server container on
the right-hand side as consisting of
several layers typically inside who
watch the machine when you're running a
Windows Server container that's in the
red box there is of course a host OS
right that's Windows Server host OS
that's running on top of that there's a
container runtime like docker and on top
of that runs your Windows server
container and a container of Windows
Server container like you can see here
is composed of multiple layers typically
you know there's a base OS layer image
at the bottom obviously and above that
there are a number of custom layers that
you can add on top it can be I is
partial etc etc right a lot of things
you can add on top of the base OS layer
and then on top of that sits your
application that in a sense is really
how you make containers right windows
server containers that's was well
hopefully it was a quick overview for
those of you who are early in in you
know windows server containers land now
as you make choice of your Windows
Server containers and you make those
containers of your applications a couple
of things I wanted to kind of run by
very quickly the first thing you'll be
doing is selecting your underlying host
OS now as many of you may know from
Microsoft there are two releases or two
channels that
Microsoft has four windows server one
they call long-term service channel and
the other is called semiannual Channel
LTS see examples of that are you know
Windows Server 2016 2019 and so on and
of course on a semi-annual channel
release schedule these are released
every six months or so so the latest one
is 1809 and usually the numbering or the
build numbering for that follows the
year and the month after that right so
that's the key difference between those
two releases a couple of quick things to
note there if you are looking into
containers I'll point out the support
that Microsoft provides for either of
them is a little bit different so you
want to make your choice for underlying
host OS based on that if that's of
importance but that said there's a lot
changing with the server containers in
fact updates are being released now a
very frequent basis so the
recommendation from Microsoft is
obviously to use the semi-annual channel
for your container applications because
then you can keep up to date with all of
that good tech that's coming out and
rolling into these semi-annual updates
right so that's kind of a little bit
about choosing the underlying host OS
now going one layer up as you're
choosing your next layer of your Windows
Server container you have to make a
choice on what kind of a base image you
want inside of your container there are
two broad types of base images that you
can choose from the Windows server core
and the windows nano server the key
differences between them are of course
one is of size for those of you who may
know Windows server core when you
download from the registry is a little
over 2 gig and of course uncompressed it
can you know walked about 5 gig right
Windows nano server on the other hand is
very tiny almost compares to Linux
container sizes when you download that's
under hundred Meg now and of course when
you explode that up by it's a little bit
over 200 Meg now the scenario is where
you'll be choosing either or are going
to be dependent on your applications if
you want a lot of compatibility for your
legacy applications with the older stuff
you want to go for server core of course
a lot of the new applications like
dotnet core iis asp.net etc can will do
just fine in nano server the usual rule
of thumb is go with nano server if for
some reason compatible reason you cannot
of course go down the left side right
with Windows server core
so hopefully that's a little bit of a
tip on choosing the next layer for your
windows server containers now one of the
things that it's kind of like a little
bit different in the world of Windows
server containers versus what you may
have been used with Linux containers is
that you must make sure that you have to
match the host and the container OS
versions so you know this is just a bit
of a gotcha if you're especially coming
from linux world to kind of like make
sure those two match and when it comes
to windows server numbering system for
versions there are four numbers right
there is major minor build and revision
now the first three are the ones that
have to match the last one it's okay for
it not to match the revision number is
typically a number that gets updated
every time you you apply a patch like a
KB patch to your image right so that's
the key difference just real estreet a
quick example let's say if you have a
container image and a host OS version
and those diversions that they're
running if you end up let's say
upgrading our rather applying a patch
update to the host OS version and you
don't update or apply that same patch to
your container image it'll just work
fine however if you upgrade the
underlying host OS let's say to the next
build and you do not do that for the
container it just won't run right like
it's not even a it just won't even start
so right so just kind of like something
to remember as you're thinking about
what version to choose and how to mix
and match your sort of container and
host versions now we get a lot of these
questions from customers also on
licensing right how does licensing work
for Windows containers so I just wanted
to spend a minute on that now the way
Microsoft treats container licenses is
that they are supplements to the
underlying host OS licenses what that
basically means is if you are running a
licensed host OS inside of a William you
can run containers write your license
actually covers for that so the good
news is in GCE as long as you're
spinning up your Windows Server VMs
you're already licensed for because
you're paying for the license on the
underlying sort of virtual machine you
can run any number of containers on top
and because Windows Server 2008 uh
Center and standard editions allow you
to run unlimited number of Windows
Server containers there's a ton of
savings you can actually get you know by
packing a lot of those containers on on
one OS the other key point
sort of mentioned here is if you are
running containers on top of a host OS
you can only do that for running
containers so you can't have some
containers and you know you have
something else run on top also
that's what right on the right side of
the slide it says right it has to be
used solely to run containers so that's
kind of like a licensing term as well so
hopefully some some tips here on
licensing now of course you know we get
a lot of questions from customers many
of you are thinking about how to
basically container eyes what you can't
inner eyes what not those are also those
are all great discussions and it's hard
to come up with a prescriptive guidance
for that sort of a question honestly
just now you heard from Alex's to the
journey that they have embarked on
especially as they sort of modernized
and containerize their applications and
your journey could be you know very
similar or very different honestly in
many cases what I do recommend to
customers is that have a bit of a
checklist that you prepare for
applications and have some criteria by
which you assess those applications
whether they are container risible or
not and some of course tips are here on
the slide great candidates for continued
ization generally are you know your web
and logic tiers in-house dotnet apps if
you've got custom apps that you develop
yourself because you know the code and
you can continue right them and of
course slightly more recent applications
that are perhaps I is 6 plus or you know
3.5 dotnet framework and onwards and of
course new applications that you develop
in using micro Services architectures
and/or cloud native applications also
make for great candidates for containers
now some of those applications that you
want to stay away from for a little bit
at least is you know any application
that has a UI experience right because
containers won't give you that RDP vdi
are examples kind of like to stay away
from for now and especially if there's
an underlying dependency your
application has on GPUs or TP use or any
low level networking constructs out
there you want to kind of like you know
look at it a little bit more closely
before you decide to continue rise and
of course with 80 integration that's
something that's in the works so I would
say you know keep keep looking out for
that upstream communities has that an
alpha support and of course we will have
plans to support that as well but that's
something to absolutely keep on lookout
for one thing I'll mention here is that
any of those any of the things that are
important to you that on the right-hand
side do talk to us because the world is
changing very quickly we're adding a ton
of innovation as is a Microsoft as well
with container
so we're all listening to your feedback
so keep talking to us now outside of
that in Google Cloud we've been of
course supporting Windows Server
containers for a while if you go to your
management console and open up the menu
there are a number of images already
that you can get started with today and
if you choose one of these container
optimized images for Windows Server they
come in with docker pre-installed right
so you don't have to install docker
yourself they call them they're all
ready to go and they have server core
nano server images already downloaded
and loaded up in the local registry
inside of those virtual machines so if
you want to give it a spin immediately
you can do so without having to download
them on the wire again and then of
course GCP does have a cloud registries
for you to kind of make modifications if
you want those continuing images push
and pull those images if at your will
which of course is going to be a lot
more important as you look at kubernetes
and the Jiki of course as well for your
applications and if you're interested in
learning a little bit more about you
know how do you take a dotnet
application containerize it etc there is
a session that we're running later today
we'll go into a little bit more of depth
and show a demo as well for that now
obviously that was a whirlwind tour of
hopefully Windows Server containers some
hopefully some tips and tricks for those
of you who are very early in this
journey with us now let's shift our
attention to talk about orchestration
with kubernetes usually we'll be
covering a little bit about kubernetes
and then talking about our plans to
support it in gke in the next you
through high-level overview of Windows
Server containers with kubernetes and
then with gke and then I'll wrap it up
with a demo
so if you don't know about kubernetes
already it's the leading container
orchestration system out there it helps
you automate deployment of your
applications managing their life cycles
and scaling your applications as needed
so this technology was actually inspired
by Google's experience of running
billions of containers in generally over
the years and is completely open-source
and runs in multiple clouds so here is
an over simplified view of kubernetes
architecture at the bottom you have to
work in those which are typically
virtual machines running your workloads
and then you have the master control
plan at the top that includes API server
scheduler and various controllers so a
kubernetes user would just write a
workload specification indicating how
many replicas they want what kind of
container image to use and then submit
this spec to the api server which will
get dispatch eventually CH unto the
worker knows and then we have the panel
agent which is cubed that would start up
the containers and manage them for you
so kubernetes started with Dennis
containers only but in the past two
years the community has been working
closely with Microsoft to support
Windows containers so I'm happy to tell
you that just in the last month in the
kubernetes 114 release Windows Server
containers running on Windows knows were
declared as a stable feature so kudos to
all the community members who helped to
make this happen
[Applause]
so how do windows server containers work
in kubernetes
so that's see an overview of this so
here we have the architecture again and
you have the master control plan so this
master control plan was still run on
Linux currently there's no plan to make
it run on Windows but then you can add
windows nose so those worker nodes will
be running on Windows Server 2000 19
which is a requirement with a one point
14 release and then on those nodes we
again will have four no agents running
so with the windows nose now you can run
Windows paths so pod is the part is
composed of multiple containers it's a
basic scheduling unit in kubernetes so a
posture containers in the pub in the
posture a single IP address they can
share volumes to access the same set of
data and users can customize their paths
to use custom hooks or health checks and
also a park and access config maps or
secrets which are kubernetes concepts
for configurations or storing of
sensitive information and then of course
you can view the status and getting the
events and metrics for your windows
paths as you can do for your in the next
path so with pass now you can build
services a service in kubernetes groups
multiple paths with a defined access
policy for example shown on the slide
you can have a service with a single
cost single IP edges and then you can
actually have three different paths to
back up this to pack the service so the
traffic will get distributed onto those
three paths so communities supports
multiple type of services or load
balancers and we support this for both
Windows and Windows and Linux paths so
this provides cross-platform
connectivity
so we talked about pad which is a very
basic concept in kubernetes but most
users don't create past directly they
create higher-level construct that
better suits their workflows for example
a daemon set will create a part per node
or if you use job they will ensure that
a number of desired paths will run
through completion and then we have
stable set which provides stable Network
and storage identity for each path in
the set this is particularly useful if
you are using accessing a persistent
storage and if the park crashes or if
you recreate the path you want the power
to be resumed assume the same identity
and access the same piece of storage so
these are all supported for Windows past
as well
so we've only touched upon the basic
concepts in communities and what support
for Windows containers there are so many
other features they are already
supported for Windows containers and
again there will be some features that
do not work for Windows past yet and it
could be due to the inherent limitation
on Windows kernel and then the platform
and also just because the concept does
not exist on Windows at all and you will
find for in some cases even though a few
sure does work for Windows the behavior
windows pass my there might be a slight
behavioral difference between Windows
path and the next path
so there are things to watch out for and
of course the community is continuing
working on rolling out different
supporting different features and many
more will be coming in the next few
misses so that's one incentive to keep
your kubernetes cluster up-to-date so if
a curious and you want to find out more
about what features are supported you
can check out the link on the slide this
is a documentation maintained by the
kubernetes community it will get updated
frequently or if you don't trust
documentation we also have continuous
testing this is our open source testing
dashboard that's running kubernetes on
Google compute engine for Windows server
can't
yes it runs regularly every couple of
hours and you can clearly see what's
working and what's not
so kubernetes is great and many people
love it and it's widely used but a lot
of users want to focus on developing
their applications now managing the
kubernetes cluster figuring out the
operational logistics a day to day and
that's where Cecchini comes in GPA
provides of all the images of master
control plan so you don't have to worry
about the downtime of your API server
you don't have to resize your master
control plan just because you want to
scale your workload or adding more nodes
into your classroom chikka also moisés
the health of your nose and provide auto
repair mechanism if you want it and
offer different options for upgrade
there's also log in out of box logging
voluntary integration and a lot more
integration with other Google cloud
services so we are working very hard to
bring Windows continuous support to GAE
so that you get to fully experience GAE
and with branding both linux and windows
were closed so here's a preview of how
Windows Server containers will look like
I'm shaking so again the architecture
diagram but this time we have the magic
masters in the cloud so that just means
you don't have to worry about it it
doesn't need to care about what's
actually running in there right now and
indicate there's a concept called no
pool which basically it's just a group
of nodes with the same configuration for
example the same machine type the same
OS image so far we've only been
supporting the next no pause we'll be
adding a Windows no poor support meaning
that you could just add the new windows
no pour into an existing cluster and
then you can run mix windows and Lingus
watch those in the same class
so you may be wondering that but what
would happen to my Linux were close
would they get scheduled onto those
windows node and fail to run so to
prevent that from happening will be
tensing the windows no automatically so
10th is a common mechanism using cuban
80s to steer the workloads away so any
what well that cannot be run on windows
will be automatically assigned to linux
knows this ensures the backward
compatibility for your clothes so if you
if you just want to create a path that
runs on windows what would you do so in
this case all you need to do is to add a
new selector to target windows news and
in gke we will add the Toleration for
you so that it can get scheduled onto
windows node and remember that ice
mentioned previously that some of the
futures work for windows some jones and
it's actually a very complicated process
and documentation to look through to
help with our users will also be
validating the fields in the path back
making sure that the features you are
using are actually supported and if not
we'll reject right away so that you know
what's going on with your were close so
enough with the talking and that's the
in action so i'll be doing a demo
without check a cluster today so i can't
go back to the side
can we switch back to the slide one
second yeah so this is an overview of
the application I'm going to deploy
today so the application includes two
parts one is a web server hosting a
movie information this is an asp.net
core application an example that I
borrowed from Microsoft and then we'll
have a database that's running sequel
server Express database and for this
we'll be running in a safer set and
we'll be accessing a persistent storage
in this case that would be a persistent
disk in GCE so these two services will
share their credentials that they have
is credentials through a kubernetes
secret
so that's switched to the demo and to
see so to save us some time I would be
created at UK clustered like the name of
the cluster is demo and it has six notes
right now
so that's see what's actually in it so
if we scroll to the bottom you can see
there are two new polls
the first one is the t-phone own pool
which runs cause our the next image and
the second one is when which runs
Windows and we can click on it and see
that it's using Windows Zac image and we
have we have already a tent that's
already applied to the node and let's go
back to the cluster and deploy the
workflow so you can this is another view
file using a queue control which is
kubernetes come in my tool that shows
that we have six nodes right right now
in the cluster so I'm going to run a
simple script which is going to which is
just going to deploy the specs that I
have in this directory
so it's not doing any more than that
other than just submitting those specs
to the API server so while we are
waiting for the application to create we
can actually see this in our cloud
console so we can see the pass our
pending is still trying to create it but
that's fine you can actually see the
Specht of this this in this case this is
the database part so you can see that
it's a stable set and in the spec we
have environment variables which
populates and gets the secret references
and populate environment variables for
the container to use and this is running
MS sequel server Windows Express and
then we have the resource limits and
requests which are always good to have
to ensure that your notice not
overcommitted next we have the volume
months so this is the part where we want
to mount the persistent storage into the
container to make sure that we can store
our data our login our backup and
through a persistent storage
and then we have the no selector which
is a part I just mentioned in the slide
that to indicate that this is a Windows
pub we want to run on Windows nails okay
so let's go back and check out what well
seems like everything is good and that's
check the script says everything that
has been deployed so we can try and see
if we can access the website okay
so it works now we are so we have to
this movie website we can see the
details we can these are such a movie we
can actually edit it and everything will
be saved on to the gcpd so that you can
recreate a new part and access the same
set of data so this is all good but what
if it doesn't work that in the lot of
cases that's where the problem starts
that your application doesn't work as
expected and you want to troubleshoot it
so first of all we can click onto the
database and the part in this service
and actually see the CPU message CPU and
memory usage so its own it only has a
slight dot right now because we have
only been running this part for a while
but I will gather more data so we can
easily see how many what's the resource
usage of your power right now and then
if you want to use kubernetes command
line tool that's also fine so we can for
example access the box after the
happiest right now so you can see it's
running they have some error message but
it seems to be fine right now
and then you if you want to troubleshoot
a further you can also login well you
can also exact into the container so
right now we are inside the powershell
inside the database continue
so for example I can run Pierce and see
what processes are rounding we see the
sequel server a sequel writer etc and we
can also try to access the database
locally so far now you can use sequel
combine you can write sequel queries so
yep
let's switch back to the slides so we
will be launching early access programs
in 2019 so if you're please sign up for
our ap program you will get a chance to
actually influence our product in the
early stage and to make sure that we are
building what you actually need so let's
hand it back to Bangkok to talk more
about the opportunity this brings to you
with ja'kayden support thank you so much
[Applause]
so awesome thank you so much use you
I'll leave the slide at the end as well
so that you can take pictures and then
of course sign up for EAP I'm sure all
of you are excited to be joining our
program I wanted to just spend maybe a
couple of minutes on talking about the
opportunity ahead of us you know as we
talk to customers it's very clear that
you guys want to run your Windows Server
container applications with gke and some
of what we're hearing from all of you is
that it's a great migration path for
your older legacy applications if you're
especially running on older versions of
Windows Server you know Server 2008 is
going to go end of end of life and of
service by January or 2020 many of you
are looking at opportunities to take
those applications and modernize them so
this is a great opportunity for you to
continue at the same goal without just
having to just you know update and
upgrade the underlying operating system
of course with workload consolidation
you can make sure that by increasing
density using containers you can save on
the underlying infrastructure costs as
well as save on the licensing costs
right that we talked about earlier and
of course I know many of you spend a lot
of
on patching and managing your operating
systems underneath so with the
management with the gke a lot of that
sort of overhead goes out of the picture
which is which is awesome news for all
of us
and for many of you who are embarking on
new transformation initiatives modernize
modernization initiatives at your
organization's this is a great way to
kind of modernize those applications
right so tremendous opportunity ahead of
us with Windows Server is now coming
onto gke let's talk a little bit about
next steps in terms of you know how if
you are very new to GCP you know you're
not yet on GCP I would encourage you to
sign up for a trial account take Windows
Server containers for a spin and get
familiar with the Windows Server
containers world a little bit and of
course we talked about how you can sign
up for the gke
Windows Server containers support EAP do
sign up for that if that's of interest
I'm assuming you know by the excitement
in the room many of you are going to be
excited joining that program and of
course we have a number of other
sessions here that we're running on
learning a little bit more about windows
were closed on GCP at large or gke radio
sessions as well as a couple of others
that we thought of would be of interest
to you
[Music]